hey everyone it's Cameron from motion
science and today I want to do something
different that some of you aren't going
to like but most of you are and that is
I'm not going to teach today but I'm
going to talk to you instead about Black
Friday because it's almost here
[Music]
now I know that many of you have been
wanting to take some of my courses but
maybe they've been financially Out Of
Reach for you or that is to say until
now they've been Out Of Reach because I
have a very very special Black Friday
deal for you well actually I have three
so let's talk about this first one and
that is a hugely discounted offer on
stylecraft now if you don't know what
stockcraft is it is a mentorship and
training program for visual creators
motion designers looking to dramatically
upgrade your motion design skills and
build confidence in your abilities
stylecraft consists of over 80 lessons
40 project files and 30 hours of
training this program is a monster and
for Black Friday I am offering it forget
this 297 dollars or two payments of 147.
I have never offered this course at this
low of a price point if I want to make
it as accessible to as many people as
possible
so if you've been eyeing it this is your
chance how do you get this special price
you go to motionscience.tv on November
25th Black Friday and you get it then
okay Black Friday deal number two is
another huge one now if you're familiar
with the motion science workshops then
you know how valuable they are we have
created 34 of these workshops that cover
topics ranging from 2D techniques to 3D
compositing to motion tracking to
stylization and a whole lot more and
these workshops are normally priced at
49 each but for Black Friday you can get
all 34 workshops in one massive bundle
for only
297 dollars that's a savings of over 80
percent these workshops total over 51
hours of training with 150 lessons and
after effects and Cinema 4D and you will
not find training like this anywhere
else but again you have to take
advantage of this this offer on November
25th Black Friday and here's my final
deal for you on Black Friday deal number
three it is 50 off my individual courses
and texture packs this means you can get
Cinema 40 quick start for only 99 bucks
the freelance effect for only 149 After
Effects academy one two or three for
forty nine dollars each beyond title
design for 73 dollars individual
workshops for twenty five dollars each
and the grunge and film packs are going
to be on sale for 34 each so there you
have it this is the biggest Black Friday
sale I have ever done and it only comes
once a year so if you've been thinking
about getting any of these products now
is the time thanks for watching my Black
Friday Deal Video I hope you get to take
advantage of some of these special
offers and I'll see you again very soon
[Music]
foreign
[Music]